[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you made it you blowing up all over the
news
are you alone I just want the money you
got the chip all right start it up why
don't you go to the bathroom wash up
we're gonna be with you in a minute
ha ha come on man your neck it's a mess
initiating combat mode destination all
right in and out we're rich oh we are
going to the major leagues charity
hey get to clinic now histoy else
condition critical hold on hey hey just
think about all the good that we're
gonna have huh oh sorry
[Music]
take tough chip decks every corporal cop
in this city is gonna be blasting down
these doors after what you and your
psycho frantic we didn't need all this
tension damn it
[Music]
[Music]
wayde's of samurai we have a city to
burn
[Music]
please welcome Keanu Reeves
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
how's it going
all right good to see you thank you all
right all right
I gotta talk to you about something I'm
talking about something
[Applause]
CD Projekt RED cyberpunk 2077 all right
a while back the guys from CD Projekt
RED approached me and asked me to be a
part of their new project cyberpunk 2077
they were going on and on about how
they'd create this vast open world with
a branching storyline how you'd be able
to customize your character through
in-game choices and it's not something I
knew before but I was excited by and I'm
always drawn to fascinating story
cyberpunk
is said in a metropolis of the future
where body modification has become an
obsession you play as an outlaw and
enhanced mercenary working in the sleazy
underbelly of this city
yeah okay let me tell you the feeling of
of being there of walking the streets of
the future is really going to be
breathtaking alright so I guess I got to
finish this so tell me do you guys want
to know when there's one of the release
date yeah all right then check this out
[Applause]
whoa way easy
mr. Hansen am i right for the job
okay
you have gone through to the other side
let's do this
[Music]